joe biden is the man pretending to be
the president of the united states
someone is pulling his strings obviously
and occasionally they wake him up and he
gets out there and he slurs over some
words and says this that the other thing
but clearly is not in charge and every
now and again as you know at the end of
press conferences they always say mr
president i want to ask you a question
he says while they're there i'm supposed
to get going i'm going to get in trouble
for this
yesterday he gave a little press
conference and uh he mumbled something
that he thought was off camera but uh it
was not
will you take questions on inflation
then
thank you
thank you
liability
that's a great asset
more inflation
but but i thought we were supposed to
heal
i thought joe biden was going to be our
good grandfather i thought he was
supposed to be a nice man who was going
to bring the country together
after that scary orange med almost tore
us apart we almost became germany and
world war ii
but joe biden is none of those things
joe biden is as divisive as you can
possibly get joe biden actually has
policies that in many ways are ripping
this country apart joe biden has
demonized his enemies all along the way
he has demonized the unvacs he has
called most of us racist etc etc now i
don't care that he called peter ducey a
son of a [ __ ] people do these things
you know one of the problems that we
have right now is what we see on camera
is so disconnected from reality you see
these these awful people wearing masks
on camera but you know they're not
wearing masks on camera you you see them
telling you oh you have to uh you can't
go outside but we will go outside we're
going to go to parties like there's a
disconnect between the way they live
their life
and and what the public facing side of
this whole thing is so i don't really
mind that biden called ducey a son of a
[ __ ] i suspect he's called him worse
things and biden's been called worse
things and people say mean names and
sometimes i joke around and call people
names that's all good it's actually all
good it's completely fine and by the way
tension between
the president and the president's
administration and
journalists
that's good that's what you want you
don't want them constantly on their
knees showing him a good time but that's
usually what they do now the reason he
doesn't like peter ducey at fox news is
that peter ducey is basically the only
guy in the white house press corps
there's a couple news max guys who do it
too but peter ducey is the main guy sort
of the standard bearer at the moment for
someone that is willing to take the
administration to test he's actually
doing real journalism as opposed to what
the rest of them do which is oh joe
you're so great how much ice cream did
you have yeah you got out of bed joe we
love you joe
so anyway i don't really care about him
calling peter ducey a son of a [ __ ] and
by the way peter ducey doesn't really
care about joe biden calling him a son
of a [ __ ] here he is on hannity last
night we have some news tonight
uh after
years of clips of the president and i
kind of mixing it up on the campaign
trail and during the transition and here
at the white house
uh within about an hour of that exchange
he called my cell phone
and uh he said it's nothing personal pal
and we
went back and forth and we were talking
about uh
just kind of
moving moving forward and i made sure to
tell him that i'm always going to try to
ask something
different than what everybody else is
asking and uh he said you've got to
and that's a quote from the president so
i'll keep doing it did he apologize
uh he cleared the air and i appreciate
it we had a nice call he's that's not an
answer did he apologize that doesn't
sound like an apology he he said it's
nothing personal pal and i told him that
i appreciated him reaching out hey hey
john uh the world is on the brink of
like world war three right now
with all this stuff going on i
appreciate that the president took a
couple minutes out this evening while he
was still at the desk
to give me a call and clearly at least
he called you powell but you know what i
don't need anybody to apologize to me uh
he can call me whatever he wants so good
for peter dc right it's like he's taking
it in stride i suppose it's perfectly
nice that biden called him and said he
said it's nothing personal which is just
kind of a funny thing after you call
someone a son of a [ __ ] if you're
calling someone a son of a [ __ ] you're
saying your mother is a female dog that
seems personal to me if you were like ah
you're an [ __ ] like that doesn't seem
personal it's just like eh whatever but
you're saying peter ducey your mother is
a female dog
i'm a dog lover by the way but so it's
not really that offensive to me
but it's just whatever you get the point
um so i think ducey's taking it in
stride which is which is actually the
right way to do it and i'm not sitting
here saying this is the most horrible
thing but i did want to show you one
other thing on this just to show you how
ridiculous in case you don't think that
these ridiculous people in the media are
ridiculous they are in fact ridiculous
here's brian stelter this is from the
defiant l's twitter they do a great job
of showing you what these people used to
say versus what they say now
so
here is stelter up top you're seeing his
tweet from
march of 2018 when donald trump was
president and he called a journalist the
son of a [ __ ] it says calling a
journalist the son of a [ __ ] it was
wrong when trump was just a candidate
and it's even worse now that he's potus
and then he had a link to a story about
it he wrote about it because trump
called someone a son of a [ __ ] here's
what stelter said yesterday about it
when biden called someone a son of a
[ __ ] at the end of a biden photo op
when reporters when reporters shouted
questions hoping he'd respond fox's
peter ducey asked do you think inflation
is a political liability in the midterms
biden deadpanned it's a great asset more
inflation what a stupid son of a [ __ ]
biden deadpan so that's his way of
saying biden's joking when he calls
someone a stupid son of a [ __ ] but when
uh donald trump does it we're gonna
write an article and it's worse than
when he's a candidate anyway you guys
get it these people are all frauds and
ridiculous people and everything else